[Music]
the subject of this debate I suppose is
a number of terms power privilege elite
and art the relationship between art and
the lease between art and power is
extremely various across history and
we'll be interrogating that am i extreme
right if I might put it that way is
Colin McCabe was a literary critic a
film producer and author most recently I
sue most recently a perpetual carnival
essays on film and literature on my
immediate left is Paloma Strelitz whose
founder of a rather co-founder of the
Turner Prize winning assemble collective
and on my extreme left is Jennifer Scott
who's the director of historic knowledge
picture gallery so we're going to begin
with : your three minutes okay in the
late 50s
Andy Warhol anway Lichtenstein in New
York began to use consumer goods and
comics as the material for their
painting and in a way that proof that
break between the elite and the popular
was the practical example of what would
become cultural studies and at the same
time in England Raymond Williams was
elaborating his view of culture came
back into the 19th century to find an
account of culture that would honor both
his own working-class upbringing and the
great virtue of solidarity as well as
the elite texts which he had studied at
Cambridge now there are that isn't the
first time you get this breakdown you
can go back both to the modernists and
romantics and find a complication of the
notion of elite and popular culture but
it does mean that we now live in an era
where it seems to me that that
distinction means almost nothing and
you wanted an example of that you could
take the date in 1992 when the Sunday
Times actually rebranded their arts
section as culture covering every kind
of cultural production that doesn't of
course solve the problem of either value
the value of particular artistic or
cultural productions or the question of
how art reaches its audience but I think
I would find just end by saying that in
my time at the end of my time as a
cultural bureaucrat access was the key
new label word to cover all art and the
trouble about access is that it's
extremely misleading as a word in the
sense that it both means are very
physical it's the ability of a disabled
person to get access to something but it
also means that in getting that physical
access you get a set of entitlements and
when Jimmy Wales says that you know with
Wikipedia we now have all everybody has
access to all of knowledge you have to
really question for did you take the
simplest you haven't got access if you
can't read and it goes on there's
question there's access always brings
with it a further set of questions and
it does not seem to me a useful word in
discussing these matters Jennifer I
think this is a really interesting topic
for us to be discussing today I am
fortunate enough to be the director of
the UK's oldest purpose-built
art gallery it opened to the public in
1817 and with that comes huge
responsibility and the thing that I try
to keep grounded about is the fact that
ultimately Dulwich picture gallery is
about great art and I like to think
about the way that that art functions
and the power that that art has for
instance we have painting in the picture
gallery which is a portrait of a lady
called Winnie
Stanly and she died in 1633
in 1633 her husband lost her a man lost
his wife
in 1633 nearly 400 years ago it happens
to us all that we lose somebody but the
man in question was so canal Digby
so canal Digby was a member of high
society of the elites he moved in
circles that meant that he was familiar
with an artist called
Anthony Van Dyck who had come across
from Antwerp to paint the royal family
and in this early 1630s he was painting
Charles the first and his family and so
when Khanum
lost his wife his first instinct was to
call upon Van Dyck to come and paint her
corpse in bed because that was his way
of coming to terms with his loss now I
think the point you raised Philip about
patronage is so important because Van
Dyck would have never had access the
Canon Digby's grief had kinome himself
not had the wealth to pay for Van Dyck
to come and there is a certain amount of
power and control that comes with a
commission of that type but in my
experience of it once an artist is there
on the scene then they take control no
matter what the limitations of a
commission an artist has the ability
within a certain framework but we all
work within a framework and that is
where correct creativity can flourish
best the artist then takes control of
the situation and can on Digby wrote
about this painting after it had been
finished and said he painted Van Dyck
painted my late wife perfectly he got
every detail right
apart from he added a flower he added a
flower on the bed that was falling apart
that was dying Van Dyck took that moment
in the privilege of going into an
intimate grief ridden state a room and
have that ability to go in and get close
to calms late wife and then to paint her
and add in some poetic license and
there's something that I noticed when I
look at our painting and come to Daleks
picture gallery see it for yourselves
the way
that's the commercial I will but when
you come in and look at that painting
you'll notice that it's painted it's a
very strange angle because what Van Dyck
decided to do was to paint
mrs. Digby as if he was leaning right
over her and when I look at that and
it's changed in the way I look at it
over over the years when I look at that
I think that actually Van Dyck has
channeled the way that canon would have
leant over her as if he was going to
give her a last kiss and Van Dyck chose
to do that and it is heart-stoppingly
beautiful and means a great deal to me
even more so since I lost somebody
recently my mother the most important
person to me and it means so much to me
that painting so despite the wealth and
the elitism and all of the the trappings
around the creation of this painting
ultimately it's something deeply human
and that for me is a way in for people
to great art the fact that it exists at
all means that we can have a connection
to a human emotion 400 years ago that
can feel as current as if it happened
just yesterday because we can all
understand loss and we can understand
great art and we can understand the
poetry that moment when Van Dyck made
those crucial decisions to create a
painting that has so much power so the
responsibility that I have on my team
have at Dulwich picture gallery is to
try and open that up in various ways to
as many people as possible because then
people can find those connections and
can ultimately find themselves in great
art paloma thank you um yes sir I was
introduced I'm one of the cofounders of
Istanbul and we really work across the
fields of architecture art and design
I've also just finished the design of
the New Gods in a Center for
Contemporary Art which is open this
month in South London in New Cross as a
sort of new free Art Center so maybe
this is a kind of a code call out to
coming to art centers in in South London
having a nice day out and I think it's
also it's why there's a topic of today I
think really resonates as my interest so
I you know culture of improvisation and
hands-on making is a really important
aspect of assembles work and to us it
makes it possible to read and partake in
the city
bit differently so that it's no longer
quite so opaque or an unmanned
questionable and but instead sort of
full of possibility for how you might
take part in it and I think that you
know that runs alongside our interest in
creating spaces that really support
Conte different context of sort of forms
of art practice and that really has
significance across the spectrum from
the way we begin to play as children to
the way we continue to learn as adults
so I'm kind of interested in in spaces
of production as spaces of knowledge and
the cultural value and tools that they
can equip us with to begin to shape new
realities so I'm gonna very very briefly
talk about to assemble projects that
kind of I so speak to the title of this
conversation which is about how art can
open the minds of the many so firstly I
want sort of mentioned black horse
workshop which is a workshop that we set
up in Walthamstow and it really takes
the spirit of building as a sort of
collective activity and also I suppose
the idea of a studio culture and turns
that into a form of public library but
you know at Black Horse the main
resource is tools instead of books and
the mate and the librarians are
technicians for more debates tops and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you